[Music]
Amber Rose is head over heels for her
new man I love the element of surprise
on Sunday the 33 year old model shared a
photo of herself in bed with boyfriend
21 savage along with a heartfelt message
it's pretty amazing waking up every
morning feeling loved like this
amber captioned the pic just want a
complete positive energy she went on to
explain that she's been hurt a lot in
life quote I've been abused talked to
like I wasn't she been gaslighted and
[ __ ] shamed by men that I once loved and
cared about so I'm so thankful that God
brought this amazing person in my life
shortly before sharing the sweet message
amber instagrammed this video showing
her sharing a kiss with the
up-and-coming artist she captioned the
clip when he loves spoiling you but you
got your own money so you spoil him
instead and it seems the 24-year old
rapper is equally as smitten he
confirmed the two were dating while
promoting his new album last week on
92.3 the real after-party real cool
woman she nah me she treat me like a
king